لكن ليس جميعها فلا زالت موسكو
تمتلك ثلاث غواصات تايفون. فماذا
ما استهدف الامريكيون التخلص منه
من بين قدرات روسيا العسكرية هي
الامريكية انها ستساعد الروس في
تفكيك بعض من الغواصات الضخمة في
واستغلوا فترة ضعف السوفييت
بتوقيع احدى اهم اتفاقيات نزع
بداية تسعينات القرن الماضي في
عهد وكان على روسيا القيام بسحب
الجليد. فانت لا تعرف اين هي
تايكون ولا من اين ستشن هجومها.
ومنذ دخولها الخدمة ومعرفة
الامريكيين امكانياتها القتالية
على الابحار في مناطق القطبين
الشمالي والجنوبي بفضل قدرتها
من مئة وستين فردا وهي غاطسة تحت
الماء لعدة اشهر متتالية. وعندما
غواصات تايفون قادرة على استيعاب
مرافق معيشية مريحة لطاقم مكون
الميناء دون ان تغادر. انها وبحق
اعجوبة هندسية ما يعني انها لن
مما ادى الى عزل حمولتها الضخمة
من صدمة الاطلاق ويمكن ايضا
ونفسيا لكن تايفون تتوفر فيها
العديد من خصائص الحياة الطبيعية
نووي مدمر ضد البنية التحتية
لمنظمة حلف شمال الاطلسي ما
الغواصات عموما واحدة من اكثر
الاسلحة التي ترهق مشغليها بدنيا
السلاح التي وقعت روسيا
والولايات المتحدة الامريكية في
ثلاث غواصات من نوع تايفون من
الخدمة. وفعلا تم نزع المفاعلات
تايفون وبتلك الخطوة قل لم
امريكيون اظافير تايفون الروسية
راسية منذ عقود في موانئها. لتحل
محلها فئة بوري القادمة. من اهم
غواصات تايفون. وفي ديسمبر عام
ثمانية وتسعين اعلنت الحكومة
النووية من هذه الغواصات التي
تعمل بالطاقة النووية وبقيت
الروايات ومثلت الافلام عنها
فسلك الامريكان طريقا اخر
اصبحت تايفون الشبح الروسي الذي
يطارد الامريكيين. لدرجة ان وضعت
الف وتسعمائة وسبعة وسبعين الى
الف وتسعمائة وتسعة وثمانين.
صنعت ست غواصات من هذا النوع في
روسيا السوفيتية في الفترة من
على الغوص تحت الجليد وكذلك
احتوائها على معدات تكسير
الهائل يمكن لهذه الغواصة
اطلاقها حتى وهي واقفة على رصيف
نقول حياة مريحة في غواصة فهو
تعبير قد يكون بعض الشيء اذ تعد
ضربها من داخل المياه الروسية.
والاكثر من ذلك فلديها القدرة
تضطر للابحار والاقتراب من
امريكا لضربها بل يمكنها حرفيا
بناء فئة تايفون بما يصل الى
خمسة هياكل ضغط من التيتانيوم
في البر حتى ان فيها شمسا
اصطناعية. وبفضل مدى صواريخها
البحر لاطول وقت ممكن. تمتلك
غواصة تايفون محركين يعملان
في البحر لمدة مائة وثماني يوما
متواصلة. كما انها تستطيع حمل ما
سيتسبب في دمار لا يوصف في غضون
دقائق. وتحقيقا لهذه الغاية. تم
من اي انواع من المخاطر.
المحركات والتصميم يجعلان من
اندلعت الحرب النووية يمكنها بعد
ذلك اختراق الجليد لاطلاق وابل
بعدها اعصارا نوويا بداخلها
صوامع صواريخ نووية تكفي لمحو
رؤوس ذاتية توجيه وست منظومات
طوربيد عيار خمسمائة وثلاثة
بداخلها من صواريخ نووية ستنطلق
فورا من اماكن غير معروفة اذا ما
للبناء قوي متعدد الهياكل لهذه
الغواصة المرعبة. حماية الطاقم
وثلاثين مليمتر وثمان منظومات
دفاع جوي ايجلا. صنع الهيكل
كاملة عن الوجود في غضون دقائق
معدودة. جسم هذه الغواصة اطول من
حلف الناتو تايفون يظل دائما هو
الاشهر. وبضغطة زر واحدة ستخلف
يمنحها القدرة على التخفي
والاختباء وبالتالي فان ما تحمله
يقرب من مائتي رأس نووي. ويتألف
الجزء الحربي للغواصة من عشرة
ملعب لكرة القدم حيث يبلغ طولها
مئة وسبعين مترا وعرضها ثلاثة
الى ثمانية الاف وثلاثمائة كيلو
متر وتستطيع غواصة القرش البقاء
بالطاقة النووية. لتبقى فترات
طويلة للغاية تحت الماء. وهذا
من التيتانيوم. تصميمها يسهل
الابحار تحت الثلوج والبقاء في
الخارجي لهذه الغواصات من
الفولاذ الخفيف واقسام الطوربيد
وعشرين مترا. تحمل عشرين صاروخا
بالستيا من طراز كروز وبمتن يصل
تحمله في احشائها من اسلحة على
نصف امريكا او اوروبا كلها وزن
معرفة وجه روسيا المرعب فلتتأمل
في تفاصيل صناعتها واهدافها. لن
هي اكبر غواصة تم بناؤها على
الاطلاق في العالم. واذا اردت
الامريكية مثل اوهايو. التي يصل
وزنها الى تسعة عشر الف طن. نعم
النووي. تايفون. غواصة توصف
بالوحش تحت الماء. فهي قادرة بما
يعلم ما هي تايفون حينها. وكرد
فعل بعد اعلان البحرية الامريكية
يكون هناك مثيل لغواصة تايفون
الروسية التي تدعى اكولا باللغة
الروسية وتعني القرش تتعدد
الاسماء لكن الاسم الذي منحه لها
الغواصة يصل الى ثمانية واربعين
الف طن وتتخطى بذلك وزن الغواصات
عن فئة اوهايو ليصل صداها الى
روسيا هنا الامين العام للحزب
لها من ردة فعل صادمة للامريكان
حينها هنا اعلن الروس وببساطة
انهم لن يسمحوا للامريكيين
باحراز اي تفوق في ملفات الردع
الشيوعي يعلن استيقاظ الوحش ليتم
الاعلان عن غواصة تايفون. ويا
النووية الامريكية فان السوفييت
سيأتون بتايفون. لكن لم يكن احد
الامريكي جيرالد فورد انه اذا
استمر في برامج تطوير الاسلحة
غواصة القرش الروسية نتحدث
وللقصة بقية. القصة باختصار.
عسكرية هي احدى اهرامات روسيا
العسكرية يراهن عليها بوتين ولا
الباليستية وها هي تنتزع لقب
اكبر غواصة نووية في العالم عن
العالم. يستطيع نحو نصف الولايات
المتحدة او اوروبا كلها. تايفون
عندما كان الامين العام للحزب
الشيوعي الروسي قد حذر الرئيس
كلاسون مورين. حجمها يعادل ملعبا
ونصف لديها قدرات تدميرية هائلة
الوحش الذي يسكن في احشاء المحيط
ولا يستيقظ الا في حرب نهاية
يبالي امام اوروبا وامريكا صاحبة
اكبر حمولة من الصواريخ
ان قررت استخدامها في حربها
المنتظرة? الاجابة لكم يا اصدقاء
لا يمكن تخيلها. الغواصة التي
ارعبت الامريكان. هي معجزة